commemorate the 20th anniversary of
september 11 2001
as we honor those that we lost and the
heroism of all who bravely sacrificed
their own lives to save others
on that fateful day 20 years ago tonight
it'll be the young rookie luis garcia on
the hill sitting on 10 wins and six
losses a 329 era which are very good
he's tied for the lead in rookies with
those 10 wins
oh there it is right there breaks the
slump david fletcher is on the board
with a base hit to right field that's
going to bring up shoei ohtani like to
see him go the other way swings at that
one that's going to be a base hit nice
piece of hitting for shoei ohtani
and the angels with runners at first and
second nobody out here in the first
inning so jared walsh steps in one down
first and second
swings at that one sends that out
that's it very very well off the wall
that's going to score david fletcher
shoeitani is going to hold at third base
so that's a one out double and a ribby
and a one nothing angels lead here in
the first nice piece of hitting going
the opposite way for walsh luis frangifo
now runners at second and third one out
renifo chops that one to second base
altuve throws him out but that's gonna
be an rbi for renifo two nothing angels
and there's jose suarez looking forward
to seeing what he can do especially
against this lineup in the best start of
his career against the range 2-2
got him good start
little tapper reheapo comes in tough
play
oh he gets him
wind up along to center field
that one drops for a hit i'm gonna say
off the bat you think it's sit sit and
did nicely for a base hit
first pitch and ohtani grounds it softly
right side a curve ball coming on the
field at altuve and he throws out ohtani
to in the inning three and two the count
to alvarez as he takes one inside ball
four that is another walk drawn by
jordan alvarez who has now drawn a walk
in four consecutive played appearances
going back to last night
at that time that's right on the back
this could be two
and it is
excellent play right there jared walsh
so strong at first base
adele ropes that one to left field on a
2-0 count base hit speaking of crazy
that was a rocket was it joe adele
got him luis garcia wins that battle
against the guy he has struggled against
that
is garcia first strikeout of the game
brings up rentifo rbi ground out in the
first for the angel's second run
two-and-oh to renifo
swings at that one
and he hits it well
and out of here home run for renifo that
is number four on the season you're
gonna want that baseball oh that was a
quick throwback red heath bomb
hit that one out quickly get it to luis
he's got family that will take that one
and it's four-nothing halos that's some
quick hands four nothing halos bottom of
the third
oh that looks good strike three caught
him looking
got of swinging and jose suarez has
faced the minimum here's the 2-2
breaking pitch popped up a mile high
right field there's tucker can of corn
for him and he'll put it away for out
number two here comes the 2-2
breaking ball got him strike three as he
expanded the zone that time garcia gets
in his second strikeout inside because
he's so far off the plate it's trouble
oh great pitch strike three
jose altuve goes down swinging for the
second time this afternoon
into right field falling quickly there
it is first major league hit for jose
siri
a nine pitch at bad and siri will
cherish that moment congratulations jose
siri
[Applause]
oh he picked him off it's a tough throw
to walsh but he is safe at second base
he got picked off and still made it in
there
down low ball four second walk of the
night allowed by suarez
jordan with a line drive single to right
played on one hop by joe adele
siri will have to hold it third alvarez
has now been on base
six consecutive times yuli guriel
batting with the bases loaded and one
out
ground ball towards short randhifa will
go to third they get the force there run
scores
fielder's choice
and the astros get their first run of
the night is now four to one
frenjifo goes down so luis garcia
wins that battle after giving up the
two-run home run to rent hippo last time
up he comes back to strike him out here
here's brandon marsh
ball hit sharply at yuli guriel will
make the play to short correa's return
throw
in time for the double play leading this
game four to one as we move on to the
sixth inning and brandon bielak will
take over for the astros
as mayfield
hits that one to right field it gets
down into the corner kyle tucker is
there that's gonna be a stand-up double
with one out here in the sixth inning
for captain jack mayfield fletch doesn't
walk a lot
but he does right there so first and
third two outs brings up shohei ohtani
ground ball towards first euless snags
it steps on the bag and that is a big
out for black in the astros keeping this
game at 4-1
placement for defense here in this game
struck him out jose suarez gets siri
oh great pitch back
looking
strikeout number seven
make it three jordon alvarez delivers
into right center field that'll go all
the way towards the wall marsh tries to
cut it off the ball's still loose jordan
will hold up though with a two out
double he has now been on base seven
consecutive times in this series so mike
myers the new pitcher and he faces
guriel 1-2
ground ball
mayfield charges great play gets him and
gets out of the inning
two and two to correa
in a 4-1 game in the seven struck him
out
there's a ball up the middle kyle tucker
on a 3-2 pitch singles into center field
tucker now with a five-game hitting
streak a little myers on myers action
here
did he get him strike three
that one's going into center field
tucker's gonna get to third base
[Applause]
[Music]
a little bit low ball four was close
myers wanted the call doesn't get it
first and third two out bottom of the
seven steve seashek is in for the halos
that one out to right field
juan logaris is there to squeeze it and
out number three a little scary there
without to be at the plate
potential tying run there it is right
there nice piece of hitting opposite way
holds up at first base
that's a walk first and second now
the blunt just like you said to bregman
excellent job by jack mayfield brandon
marsh on third max dassey on second a
2-2 count this would be a big strikeout
if he could get it set a little pop-up
can yuli get there long run over the
shoulder makes the catch nice play by
eule and a strike to home plate
and it's a full count
walks him so lead off walk nobody out
ground ball towards the middle correa
gets a big hop to altuve in a quick
throw by altuve on the transfer for the
double play reisel iglesias what's not
to like about this situation andy
glacias he's one of our favorite guys on
this team he's been money all season
and he ropes this ball into a right
center field that'll be down another two
hit night for tucker
he walks myers here and that'll bring
the tying run to the plate
garrett stubbs will get his first at bat
of the night
that ball hit pretty well to left field
going back adele he leaps up is off the
wall
tucker will score myers to third stumps
to second astros have two on in a 4-2
game tying run at second base 2-2
got him
what a pitch frozen 97 patrick he was
looking slider got the express
mccormick
pops it up
mayfield or stassi stassi has it
ball game
[Applause]